نيجي الان لا مالك وسيد تويتر الجديد الى
النصر لما زال ماضي في رحلته اخباره ليبدو
انها ما راح تنتهي والرحله اكيد بتعرفوا
عنوانها تويتر ففي اكتوبر اعلنت تويتر انه
رح تضيف ميزه عدد المشاهدات لتغريدات
واطلقت اختبار تجريبي للميزات الى الناس
من خلال رده على احد المتابعين اللي سالوا
عن الميزات والتصميم الجديد فقال لهم ماسك
سنقوم بترتيب الجماليات ونظيف اعدادات
لايقافها واعتقد ان الجميع سيحبها يعني
بالخط العريض تويتر راح يعدل ميزات عدد
المشاهدات اللي اطلقها مؤخرا وراح يسمح
للمستخدمين بايقاف تشغيلها اذا حبون يعني
يعملوا هيك
وماسك العاده ما بيفوتوا اي تقرير اعلامي
عن تويتر وجاهز فورا للرد عليه فمن يومين
نشرت رويترز انه ازال ميزات بتساعد على
منع الانتحار والميز المشاهدين اسمها دير
از هاوس وعم نعرض لكم عينات منها وبتظهر
فقط في حال البحث عن كلمات بتدل على شيء
معين مثل كورونا او نقص المناعه كوارث
طبيعيه والعنف او غيرها من الكلمات
وخلالها بيظهرت تويتر الدعم او بيظهر
تويتر الدعم للشخص وبتكون المميزه بمثابه
منه انتحار والوقوف الى جانبه لكن الى
الماسك هاي المعلومات المتداوله بهذا
الخصوص ورد على التقرير اللي نشرته بانه
خطا والميزه بعدها موجوده ومان لغت ابدا
زي ما قال
يعني اخبار ومعلومات وروايات وسياسات
جديده وتطورات عن اشهدها يوميا حول ماسك
وتويتر ومن بين الاخبار والفوضى اللي
شفناها وشهيدناها في في شيء ايجابي نشره
له ماسك فقال صحيح انه تويتر مش امن كفايه
لكنه ليس في طريق سريع للافلاس ولا يزال
هناك الكثير من العمل للقيام فيه
[موسيقى]